hi
so we bumping into you hey
yeah everybody good you good you well
holding in there though I mean you know
all that so
how
five six five six sorry
nuts months yemen's months of course
months so what are you doing around here
I just I just live up the road yeah
I can't leave you
I one of mine whose use my seeing you
anyway
really nice
you've been to my house I live just
around the corner you do remember my
house with the bright green door and the
comedy don't Bob me have my parrot
Reggie
yeah the parrot Reggie yeah what what
great bird people who thought it was
weird I had a parrot in a it's a nice
girl like you Cassie having a parrot
they're dirty Birds
Cassie they can turn dangerous at any
time
I killed Reggie this morning I'm telling
you this because we're such good friends
I had to he gouged out calories I
remember carries I who is that such a
lovely risible think so I killed Reggie
with a spatula remember how I always
liked a good spatula so much squawking
what it was lovely seeing you again liya
[ __ ] liar whoa you don't remember me
do you
you're [ __ ] fake I could see it I
could see in your eyes I don't even have
a parrot that's how I knew and Kari is
called SIA and her I was counted out by
her malicious brother Kevin there's no
film
[ __ ] hell Colin I know we haven't
seen each other in ages but I thought
you were friends least I try least I
still make an effort because we are
friends on Facebook Colin does that mean
nothing in this day and age yeah of
course dust
my name is Nolan
what
my name's Pete Pete yeah Peter now :
nope Colin Harley Manchester but it's
like Waunakee together you just like my
friend :
Kenny spitting image but it was lovely
meeting you
paint
Oh
you